la ville de la verrière a présenté ce
mardi 16 novembre sa nouvelle maison du
projet pour recueillir les idées et les
témoignages des habitants du quartier du
bois de l'étang au sujet du prochain
plan de renouvellement urbain on a
ouvert cette maison du projet pour
permettre aux habitants de s'exprimer de
manière libre sans pression à travers
les urnes à travers les permanences à
travers la consultation des plans du
projet le projet de renouvellement
urbain comprend la démolition de 212
logements la ville de la verrière a donc
fait appel à l'entreprise séquence pour
réaliser une enquête sociale auprès des
habitants du bois de l'étang qui sont
concernés par la démolition de leur
logement on a
74% des familles qui se sont déclarés
favorables au projet de renouvellement
urbain et plus encore 85% qui se sont
déclaré
favorable à un relogement ou charte
intercommunale a été signé par les deux
maires de l'agglomération
elle garantit à tous les habitants une
question prioritaire de leur dossier il
ya 72 % des familles qui souhaitent être
logés en dehors de la commune et c'est
vrai que comme on a cinq mille logements
sur saint quentin en yvelines et cent
mille logements en ile de france
voilà c'est vrai que c'est quand ça les
capacités de faire des propositions
correspondant aux soins et aux besoins
des familles depuis le lundi 18 octobre
les habitants peuvent donner leur avis
sur les futurs d'aménagement du quartier
du bois de l'étang comme les voiries la
végétation ou encore l'e commerce tout
reste à décider avec les habitants quel
commerce quel commerce on veut qu'elle
nouvelle maison de quartier qu'à l'école
quel service voilà tous ces détails là
qui sont extrêmement importants pour la
vie du quartier il faut lui décidé avec
les habitants nouvelle voirie nouvelle
école nouvelle maison de quartier ce
plan de renouvellement urbain est
chiffré à 70 7 millions d'euros il a
également pour objectif de doubler le
pont de lavilledieu pour ouvrir le
quartier va à l'extérieur